witchcraft in general is control and
manipulation is something that you do to
get some in return do witches worship
the moon especially during Halloween
that they believe that it opens up in
the spiritual realm this this was just
accepted as common place what are the
nuts and bolts of it like at demon came
and the main wit she just got possessed
and she started to speak someone in your
family is going to die in one week my
dad committed suicide and he was hanging
[Music]
there we hear a lot about witch hunts
political witch hunts social witch hunts
and the premise of the phrase Witch Hunt
is that something is preposterous
unjust because witches don't
exist but what if they do what if they
exist what if people practice witch
craft what if they've done that for
Millennia and what if an increasing
number of people are doing that right
now what would my proof of such a wild
contention
be a former witch that would be Julie
Lopez Julie thank you for being here
Michael thank you so much for having me
here today Julie in this longer Forum
series I've talked to all sorts of
people who have tended to fall more onto
the spirit spiritual side of things H so
we've talked to people who are kind of
new Agy I've spoken to an exorcist I've
talked to a psychic I've you're the
first person I'm talking to who would
have called herself a witch and so for
for some people who might accept okay
there's a spiritual realm and maybe
there's something to you know the Vibes
and the you know the psychic powers and
whatever I think even for those people
to hear that witchcraft is real that's
going to be a bridge too far but you say
it's real it is real and I say to people
you can take what you want from me but
you cannot take my testimony and what I
lived and Witchcraft was part of my life
four generations five generations my
great-grandmother my grandmother my
mother myself and he ended in me because
of the consequences that you know
throughout Generations I realized this
has to end in me I don't want my
Generations I don't want my children to
be involved in this so I'm talking from
my own experience um this is not
something that I learn in a book or in a
movie this is something that was in my
in my family four generations that means
that your great grandmother practiced
witchcraft yeah my great grandmother was
she was a medion she was a psychic she
was the Healer so she used to move like
in different areas and um and she was
the one that introduce all all of us
into into witchcraft but something
interesting is that we never call
ourselves witches we never said oh we
are witches we are moving it no because
it was part of our DNA so we didn't have
to say to people we are doing witchcraft
or we are witches because we grow up
like that were were you conscious of it
being witchcraft at the time and you
just didn't tell people or you weren't
even I didn't you know when when I
became Christian that's when I realized
wait a minute I was doing witchcraft my
family was doing witchcraft and you know
I didn't share my testimony for like 12
years I just shared my testimony I
started to share my testimony last year
because I first of all I was a scared of
my background I was ashamed that you
know that my father died because of
Witchcraft and um and so I just sto kind
of like hiding that part of me and um
until I realized actually that we were
actually deep involved in witchcraft
like my whole F my whole
family this is might be a sore subject
so don't feel the need to go too
in-depth if you don't want to but how
did your father die from witchcraft so
that's that's that's part of my
testimony on how witchcraft ends in me
um we so we grow up with a lot of
Witchcraft towards the end of my father
dying we got involved in Black
witchcraft which is the Witchcraft that
you use to harm people to control to
Witchcraft in general is control and
manipulation but towards uh that year we
were just involved in witchcraft because
my mother got connected to a friend that
was a black Witch uh so someone the most
in Black Witchcraft and she started to
train me she saw me and she said you
know your daughter has a gift and we did
a ritual and they consecrated me to one
of the three Venezuelan Powers which is
a principality is a is a demon of high
rank and he became my spirit guide he
became kind of like my guide and I used
to go to him for rituals if I needed
needed something so I started to learn
when he was in a room smell his presence
feel his presence and also I started to
get super depressed suicidal because
also the spiritual realm works with
blood so when you are increasing in
power also the things that you have to
do increase in power so these demons
will ask you for maybe do sacrifices or
do something deeper blood is part of
that so I didn't realize that through me
cutting myself right I was making a
covenant with this demon because the
blood is powerful for initiation of
covenants so I didn't realize that
through me doing that subconsciously I
was giving power to this demon I was
making a covenant with him and so so you
were harming
yourself but not not in a conscious way
saying this is part of the richcraft
ritual that you were just doing it
because you were depressed at first it
was part of the ritual but after that it
I just became suicidal I ended up in the
hospital I tried to commit suicide
because I felt so tormented and that was
when um we did a ritual in the entrance
of the house with all the witches we
were there we were speaking in tongues
and after the a a demon came and the
main witch she just got possessed and
she started to speak these words and
this which look at my mom and told my
mom like someone in your family is going
to die in one week so I look at my mom
and I told her let's I don't want to
know because I was so suicidal that I
didn't want to know my mom started to
cry and this demon started to ask my mom
do you want to know who it is do you
want to know who it is and I look at my
mom my mommy started to cry and I was
like let's let's close please so we
close and one week later so by this
point I was leaving with this H which my
mom call us at like 4: in the morning
for 5 and she said you have to come home
quick so when I went when when I went
home
my mom was outside completely sh crying
with my 2-year-old brother and I was
looking for my dad so I was calling him
like like Dad that that I enter the
house and when I enter the house I felt
this heavy atmosphere it's like someone
put a cloth on me and I couldn't even
walk when I went to the room I couldn't
find my dad so I ran outside and I have
the feeling to check next to the storage
that we had close to the house and when
I push my dad committed suicide and he
was hanging there and when I saw him for
me that was the moment where my my whole
existence just collapsed my whole family
go ruin and we realized that so the
witch that was training me in black
witchraft um the person that my mom was
friend with she basically was kind of
like she came with a mission she came
not only to train me and to you know but
also she came to destroy my my family
and in fact as soon as my dad
died she stopped having she stopped
speaking to my mom so my mom realized
like wow and my mom had also a friend in
Colombia that she used to be a white
witch and she told my mom be careful
with her because she's not coming with
good intentions she's going to destroy
your family and also when she tried to
Asal project to my house she said I
cannot enter your house because there is
a blood cloth there is some some one of
her rank taking over your house you are
in danger but my mom thought you know
what she's been crazy she she she's just
being territorial so she stopped talking
to her so when my dad died this witch
knew because she saw it in the spirit so
she called my mom and my mom cry and she
said yes he di yesterday this and this
happened and she told her cut all
communication with this witch and that's
what we did but my mom realized straight
away that our family got destroyed
because of Witchcraft I didn't realize
just yet because I had trauma I had
anger I hated my my mom so I was blaming
her so I contined to Witchcraft I left
my mom I went to live alone I was 18 I
became alcoholic drinking more suicidal
but my mom she repented because she knew
witchcraft kill my husband we did this
we we gave authority to these demons we
did something that we weren't supposed
to do and um yeah that's that's how my
testimony ends is it possible that the
Witchcraft
narrative is just a a way to
explain the natural events that took
place in your family to me I'm Christian
what you're saying makes perfect sense
and I I don't bat an eye lash at it for
people who are sex
or who don't believe in this stuff which
is a lot of people probably they'll say
oh no maybe her father was just
depressed and maybe she intuited and
inferred that there were these other
problems going on and so when it
happened then after the fact they
imposed this witchcraft narrative on it
but that was all just a bunch of mumbo
jumbo to explain perfectly
ordinary social phenomena that were
going on what maybe you've heard that
reaction before if not what would you
say to that I have he that before but I
always come back to the experience that
we had when we were doing the ritual at
the entrance the demon came and the
demon released a war over my house
saying someone in your family is going
to that in one week in fact after one
week right my dad di so my dad wasn't in
that ritual he didn't he he didn't know
he didn't even know that we were doing
that right so that for me is like the
the perfect example of like these things
are real we didn't make this up there
was a course release over my house a
demon we open a portal because when you
do rituals and the entrance of the house
you're welcoming everything possible to
enter in your in your house and I
believe that there's a lot of people a
lot of people are looking for a
spiritual experiences so because people
don't know where to go this is why
people are going to need new age people
humans are desperate for Spiritual
things because it's part of us before we
are humans We Are Spiritual Beings so
people right now children teenagers
grown-ups are looking for the experience
on where is the place where they feel
like they are finding the sne this is
how I feel about have you heard of
burning man it's this music festival
that takes place in the desert and
70,000 people go and there music and
drugs and kind of odd you know things
that they shouldn't be doing with their
bodies and then it culminates in the
burning of a giant Idol just a Hu The
Burning Man and they set it on fire and
it's a weird Pagan religious ritual
which is not good and obviously it's
kind of the topic that we're talking
about here but I I at least sympathize
with them because I think well they're
looking for something they they they
know that life is about more than just
money and work and Netflix
so they want something and they're just
unfortunately looking for love in all
the wrong places exactly and that's
exactly what is happening that we are A
Spiritual Beings and there's people that
are looking for that in the wrong places
and I believe that you can access the
spiritual realm through different ways
the Bible says in John 14:6 that Jesus
is the way the true and the life the way
but then if you go to John 101 it says
but those that climb in another way are
are thieves and robers so that makes me
think okay Jesus is the way he is the
only way but there are people accessing
what being given to us through Jesus in
another way that's why like there's
people that you know do different types
of rituals because for you to access the
spiritual realm you need blood that's
why G Jesus said the blood of my
Covenant the blood is powerful to access
the spiritual realm but it's also
powerful for the initiation of covenants
so this is why there's a lot of people
they understand witches and satanis or
they understand that there's something
in the blood right and that there's
people that are looking for that and I'm
like you don't have to look for there is
one way and this is the right way and
this is the legal right way yes you can
access that through other means but
that's illegal that's not the right way
exactly that's not the right way of
doing it and I just realized that we
have everything here we have the power
of the blood of Jesus we don't need any
other sacrifice Jesus is the perfect
sacrifice we have everything in here so
why you are going to go you know to the
counterfeit to the chip it's like if you
have like a Prada bag right and then you
go that copy why if you have the real
thing here you're are going to pay and
go for less and also the enemy doesn't
give you anything for free he doesn't
give you anything for free and then we
have in here salvation is free the if he
gives you something he's going to ask
you for something in return later on
this is why we have even so many people
that have made covenants With the Enemy
that end up dying end up committing
suicide end up uh drugs all of those
things why they couldn't take it you
know this is such an important
observation you're making about the the
importance of sacrifice because I think
a lot of people today they look at the
traditional Mass you know Holy Mass and
the center of it is is the re
presentation of the sacrifice at Calvary
of our Lord's sacrifice at Calvary they
say why the sacrifice why the focus on
the blood you know turning the host into
the body and blood of our Lord Jesus
Christ and you say well o older kinds of
people before modern liberalism came
around they understood the importance of
sacrifice every Pagan tribe in history
would sacrifice animals to whatever
demons they they were worshiping and so
there there's there's obviously deep
spiritual significance today we just
think of I don't know you know you you
watch a lecture or you you know you just
meditate or something there's the the
active sacrificial aspect of worship
seems to have been downplayed but that
for all of human history that wasn't
true even in the history of your own
family so I want to get back to this
point that it was your great grandmother
who got you all involved in this how did
she fall into witchcraft I mean I
believe it was coming even before for
her because when I when I was born she
was already SE 70 years she died in
2019 she accepted Jesus and all of the
stuff she repented but we believe that
it was coming even before her that there
was like her her family trying and un
raise her because she grew up doing that
she was like the the the witch in her
Village she was the shaman she was the
psychic she was the medion she was The
Exorcist even like people she used to
use um she used to heal people too so
she was like a big person in her Village
which make us think that it it was
coming even before that we say four five
who knows maybe like it was even more
than that this could have been going
back centuries for all you know
yeah so this was just
accepted if someone today in a suburb of
New York said okay I'm the village witch
people would look at that person well I
don't know actually
these days maybe not 20 30 years ago
people would look at that person and say
you're totally crazy but this this was
just accepted as common place and then
your grandmother accepted it and then
your mother accepted it and you accepted
it
too but you drew a distinction between
white witchcraft and black witchcraft so
she did the and the white witchcraft is
supposed to be the more benign there
different types of Witchcraft and
there's green black
red so the why witchcraft just to
explain super quick so witchcraft in
general is is control and manipulation
is something that you do to get
something in in return so why witchcraft
is the type of Witchcraft that people
use to connect with n is they don't use
that to Herm they think that they are
doing things for good they are doing
that type of Witchcraft to help people
super connected with nature with the
animals to that that type of worship
then you have the green witchcraft which
is the type of witches that use um a lot
of nature a lot of herbs kind of like
remedies things like that so you if you
are a witch you can be moving in in in a
lot of different things and then the the
black one is actually the one that's
used to harm people is the one that you
use to to control to kill to put to put
courses to destroy family to destroy a
marriage and um so there are different
ones so my great-grandmother she used to
move in a view she used to move in green
witchcraft which is type of like the the
healing the the the the herbs the Saints
to heal she used to move in white
witchcraft too and in Black I guess
today we'd call someone a witch doctor
if they mixed up little potions and but
that's just that right now now that's
been supplanted by modern medical
science which I'm not convinced has a
better track record of bodily healing
than all the crazy witch doctors of
several centuries ago but that's a
discussion for another time so that that
you might call I don't know like an
alchemist or something like that mixing
different herbs and and things but the
the difference there is not just you
mixing and doing natural things I think
the difference there is that you also
call out to Spiritual Beings to to to to
come upon that thing that you are doing
and release that so I think the
difference is that witchcraft you use
Spirit guides familiar guides so what
whatever you are doing you believe that
something is guiding that which spirit
is guiding what you are doing so you you
mentioned a familiar guide and this is
when I think of Witchcraft I think think
of broomsticks I think of uh crystal
balls and I think of black cats which is
had a black you had a black cat I did
but it wasn't because of
Witchcraft was yeah it was actually all
all naturous but art unknown to me
so the typically the way the black cats
are portrayed in witchcraft stories is
that they're the familiar familiar
spirits so what is the familiar spirit
so a familiar spirit is basically a
demon that is assigned to a family four
generations so it can come for like four
or five generations so it's a it's a
it's a it's a spirit that at the time
especially like if you come from
generations of Witchcraft right it's a
spirit that it will it comes to you
because of your ancestors so it's
someone that helps you to do the I'm
saying this but it's not like that they
are demons they um they help you with
the rituals with the potions they kind
of also act as guide and also as
protector so that's that's that's the
thing and um so when I did a ritual
before my dad died I was consecrated to
this spirit guide so he became my my
spirit gu but they can take the form of
animals that's why the blood Cuts but
this is the thing with people that I
find really interesting is that the
concept of witches and broom and sticks
and blood cats like is not just you even
have witches in government wit is like
you know ruling Nations and you don't
even realize of this concept of like no
witches right now are hiding behind nice
dresses behind you you know you are not
going to see a witch with a long nose
and saying I am a witch no because right
now they are ruling government ruling
Nations through what they are doing
releasing those Spirits those demons
through the position that they have so
is Al Al important to to just make sure
that people come out of the mindset of
like that's not just witchcraft that you
see now in so in society what the enemy
is trying to do in Nations even here in
the USA through Witchcraft and we think
like this is normal no but I thought
Hillary lost the 2016 election so at
least we got a little respit for but but
you're saying that putting putting Miss
rodm Clinton aside for a second uh that
these practices
are being done by prominent people and
in fact speaking of Hillary Clinton we
know that because Hillary's top campaign
team invited a woman over to have a
spirit cooking dinner which was just a
witchcraft performance and the the best
excuse they had was that this was a kind
of performance art and don't look too
into it but it was explicitly a
witchcraft kind of ritual do you have
evidence though that there are people in
governments around the world that are
actually doing this stuff or is it just
your interest no I know that and even in
my country now like I live in in
Colombia now last year before the
elections um when I was praying for the
new H the new president and all of that
like I found out that the president in
fact um the one that's president now
before the elections he went to a trive
in Colombia and he got a ritual done and
the vice president right now in Colombia
she is a witch
did you find this out as a matter of
sort of private Revelation or you mean
like people were talking about it I was
thinking it and then it was all over the
news you for the rituals that they were
doing this is my point he not hiding he
everywhere and he no hide they are just
doing it so you know like the enem is
not hiding anymore the enemy is out
there you see in movies TVs music you
you know recently we saw this concert at
Travis Travis Scott yeah yeah that was a
huge ritual that ritual I mean his the
stage looked like something out of Honus
BOS that was a
portal because it looked like a devil's
mouth or something and people were so so
that wasn't just a coincidence because
they tried to poooo all the criticism
and they said no no it was just uh you
know provocative imagery but people that
you know people like me that we come
from that we knew that was a whole
ritual right there because I believe he
got the power through Satanism and
through this type of thing so for him to
go to the next level you have to do
something you have to do some sort of
sacrifice that was a huge thing right
there that he did the essent the
platform was a portal the things that
the the sounds that they were playing
when that was happening they are really
low sounds that open in the spiritual
realm portals of death and portals for
these demons to enter so what was
happening there it was a sacrifice a
human sacrifice people died at this
coner oh lots of people people that
don't know anything about the spiritualy
they don't believe in in in in God in
nothing they said we felt that something
was putting our soul out of us they felt
that there was a weird atmosphere so
it's really interesting that even people
that are not spiritual they were saying
it felt like something was pulling us
out we felt suffocated we couldn't
breathe and I'm like because you were
part of a ritual in fact the people that
didn't die probably now were curs and
have open portals in their in their life
because they were part of something when
you want protect your data you've got to
go to
expressvpn.com
YT as you know there are a lot of people
who want to look at what you are doing
online the government the isps the big
tech companies they all are digging into
your stuff and so you should use the
number one rated VPN on the market not
just according to me but according to a
number of outlets and authorities as
well that would be
expressvpn head on over there right now
we've got all sorts of great deals in
promos if you are a listener and a
viewer of this show do not wait you got
to go immediately over to
expressvpn letter y letter T that is
expressvpn.com
[Music]
Michel YT today again being Christian
like these I I
just it's not that I believe every story
that I hear but I'm open to the
possibility that this this stuff exists
and what you're describing is right out
of a medieval Legend you know what
you're describing is right out of a
classic horror movie on this stuff the
low
sounds have a have a spiritual analog
the The Cutting and the blood is
physical but then it has a metaphysical
implication to it and I I see all of
that so
then what are the nuts and bolts of it
like you you tell me that the witches
don't have green skin they don't
necessarily have big warty scal noses
they don't necessarily fly around on
broomsticks I don't know maybe they do
so what is the what is the day
today look like for a witch what's the
fact from fiction I can tell you from my
experience what we were doing we went in
running running around in in BR sticks
or doing those type of things but for us
it was it was normal waking up every
every day sets up some candles and
cleansings for the house doing some also
cleansings on our own on ourselves
preparing for for the day um and just
taking with us all the protections the
crystals these type of things reading
tarot cards that's kind of like our
day-to-day look like um and then when we
were outside as I said we never said to
anyone like we are witches we are doing
this we would just walk around and be
normal people you know the the Bible is
it takes a pretty harsh line against
witchcraft Thou shalt not suffer a witch
to live you know that that sort of thing
um and I remember reading it at first
thinking well that's a pretty harsh line
against something that's not real why
why are they why is God so insistent
that people not do something which is
not possible to do and now I have a
little bit more of an open mind on that
I guess but but why is scripture
so harsh on witchcraft in particular you
know e even more than certain other sins
I think it's because witchcraft
counterfeit what God has given us as a
spiritual people when I come out of
Witchcraft I started to realize that
there were so many
similarities that I was doing on that
side that when I became Christian I
realized like wow this is like the real
thing and this is the opposite one of
them was for example in the Bible we see
prophetic acts we see the anointing oil
we see in the Bible the salt where
Prophet Elijah did a prophet at we Sal
in the water right and then you see that
which is you Sal for cleansing for
purification for curses
for cursing people drying all of those
things and then you also have the
rainbow right the rainbow the enemy
counterfeit absolutely everything you
have also the blood as I was saying the
blood is powerful for covenants we have
the blood of Jesus so when I came out of
that I realized wow this is this
witchcraft is trying to kind of steal
and counterfeit what represents God so I
believe that's why God is so strict and
so like don't witchcraft don't go to
medians don't do necromancy why because
between God's kingdom and the occultism
and Witchcraft there is a really thin
line that even you as a Christian you
can be stepping in Without You realizing
so that's why we have to be careful and
I believe that's why God Is So drastic
to like don't do that because the enemy
scoping is taking this that is God's
kingdom is taking it for his kingdom and
I feel like that's one of the reasons
Pro probably most of all the different
witchcraft flavors you know it's like a
bag of Jolly Ranchers the green and the
purple and the red and the white U the
the most dangerous would seem to me to
be the the white witchcraft CU it seems
the nicest so it seems the most
palatable and therefore but it's not
it's not good right it's not actually
benign no because all type of Witchcraft
is bad regardless of what you do you you
read tarot cards you go outside to speak
to Nature or do things in nature or you
think you're doing this for the universe
whatever you are doing is bad why
because it's counterfeit because we have
the Holy Spirit and then in here you
have another spirit that is guiding that
experience so actually the question that
we should ask is like okay who is
guiding your experience this is the real
thing if it's not the Holy Spirit then
it's another Spirit then is witchcraft
new age do do witches go out into the
woods and worship the moon this is
something that comes up in really that's
that really happen do happen especially
during Halloween there is like a certain
connection with the moon there is
certain connection with stars with the
blue moon with the red moon with all of
those things that they believe that it
opens up in the spiritual realm so
something important to understand is
that there are principles for the
spiritual realm as I was saying with the
with the blood with the sacrifices with
the it might look like oh this is
ancient this is weird coming from a book
but this is a spiritual principles and
this happens and this is happening today
this is the Satanist they are doing it
because they understand that that there
is something so they they go out they do
rituals when there's full moon they do
rituals when there's like no even ritual
just go outside and may maybe like
dancing around because they believe and
this is why I believe as Christians we
need to step into the power and the
fullness that the Lord is giving us not
just just not just going to church and
just clapping hands but there's more
than that the Lord has given us the
authority and the power through Jesus
Christ to take over Nations to impact
the Earth so why are we believing like
oh this is just coming from a book when
in reality wait a minute this has been
given to us what we are doing is kind of
like blocking what the Lord has given
and just thinking this is not real this
this doesn't exist okay you live your
life and I will continue to do God's
work in here that's a really important
point because in modern Christian
circles Protestant and to some degree
Catholic too you'll see a kind of
political quietism creep in meaning this
notion that the church should not be
involved in public life we just we have
our freedom of worship in our own houses
of worship sometimes when they're not
shutting them down or burning them down
based on blood liel like they did up in
Canada uh but we shouldn't interfere
with h public policy or anything like
that I think
well if it's true if if all this stuff
is true then it should be true in public
just like it's true in private and if
it's not true then what are we doing
right you know the the earlier
conception of religion was that of
course it's a public thing the the
ancient pagans believed that religion
was a public matter of course MH major
the temple to Athena was not only uh you
know religious place but also a kind of
Monument to the glories of Athens of of
of course the sports festivals were were
religious festivals always and then at
the height of Western Christendom and
Eastern Christendom I guess for that
matter you had not a a a total uh
overlap of the church and the state but
a fair bit of overlap at least the two
work together because every state is
going to worship something you know
everybody's got to serve somebody so so
how is that going to be informed is that
going to be informed by paganism is that
going to be informed by private
Intuition or is that going to be
informed by the church if you really
believe that Christ instituted a church
on Earth and said you know go forth make
Apostles of all Nations well he's
talking about Nations isn't he really
important point we we do have Limbs and
minds and we live in time and space and
we can actually do things to affect the
world around us not just exactly all
right my rant is over I just that was
such a good point that you brought up
and and we we ignore that all too much
but the other people don't ignore it and
that's my point this is why when I come
out of that I saw the church and I'm
like oh Lord uh you really want me and I
feel like a lot of people that come out
of the occultism right not just me but a
lot of people that I have talked to that
are trying to come out of of that they
say something they say like oh I'm
trying to come out of that but I feel
like I'm losing my power you know why
because they see the church and the
church is asleeping and I'm like no no
no no listen you're not going to lose
your gift because the the gifts are are
the and the calling are irrevocable
that's something that the Lord has given
to you but the enemy is grabbing your
gift for his kingdom for his use but
this is the point that just because you
are a Christian it doesn't necessarily
mean that you have to be sitting in a
church it doesn't necessarily mean that
you have to be not all the time at
least we have been given a mission we
have been given a voice we have been
giving the Holy Spirit to impact so we
as the church why are we going to allow
Darkness to advance if we have the power
and authority through Jesus Christ to
conquer and to take over
Nations right you know a phrase that's
fallen out of use is the notion of the
church militant you know there's the
church suffering there is the church
triumphant in heaven and then there's
the church militant that's us here you
know in time and space on Earth and a
priest friend of mine once said that
there are too many pacifists in the
church militant too many people just
passively letting things go by but of
course uh our enemies are not are not
doing that they're they're quite active
so you point out that this has been
going on for many generations who knows
could have been centuries in your
family it's seems like this is all
getting worse it seems like the occult
and Witchcraft is growing you you hear
about covens cropping up witches against
you know this conservative politician or
this Christian public figure he hex's or
do you remember there were witches who
said they were going to put hex's on
Brett Kavanaugh who was a the Supreme
Court Justice um it seems like it's
becoming more prominent is it just
always been this way though it's been
always the same way but I I believe that
now is getting more power is getting
more is is been more exposed it's been
more open now to the point that it's
becoming normal it's becoming normal in
schools it's becoming normal in society
it's becoming normal to have a president
that's running the country that is a
witch is becoming normal we don't see
anything normal but it's been there for
for Generations nothing has changed the
only that has changed is the way that we
perceive it now but it's still the same
the the same rituals the same blood the
same demons the same Spirits is the same
the only thing is that now is coming out
more but I believe is is the same what
do you say to people who object to all
of this because they say look yes
primitive societies they believed in
witchcraft but that was just a way to
explain the inexplicable and now we have
science and so now with much better
Precision we can cure diseases we don't
need to go to a white witch to cure your
cough you can just take penicillin or
something and so we're we're
demystifying the world and we're not
finding demons anywhere and the witches
or whatever they're doing they're
they're just mistaken and they're taken
to Flights of Fancy broomstick or not
and so just take your medicine you know
read the statistics live your
mechanistic life and uh ignore all that
stuff I mean obviously I'm not science
istic I don't I don't think that the
material explanations are sufficient but
a lot of people do it's that's very
persuasive because science has done a
good job of explaining many aspects of
the physical world what's your answer to
that what is my answer to that let me
tell you a little testimony my husband
when I Mar marry him I was I have always
been quite spiritual can sense things
around so always since a really young
age even when I I became Christian I was
still quite sensitive see things feel
things my husband was the opposite of
that he didn't believe in God he was
like that he was always would like to
see what are the statistics what is this
so for me it was quite hard right and he
he was close to the idea of like okay
there is a spiritual realm there is
there is something I have to be able to
see I have to be able to see the numbers
like this is maybe this is not like that
so I just let him be and you know what
he had Supernatural experience he have
here the voice of God amand that was
completely close to the idea of Rel
religion or to a spiritual things is
aand that now feels things in the spirit
why because he opened up himself he
decided like okay if this is real I want
to I want to know what what is happening
and he hear the audable voice of God he
has dreams he has Visions so this is
something that I tell people the first
step for you to open up to this and to
realize that you you know that there is
a God and there is more than that is to
give it a try just open up yourself and
just and just okay Lord if you are real
that was what my husband said if you are
real speak to me right and because of
what I do I cannot do anything my
husband doesn't agree with so we always
have to be in agreement with the things
and that's why God has been working on
him so what would I say to these people
is that open up just just give it a try
give Jesus a try and just see that all
of these things are real that you are
going to start to have dreams CU I
believe with all all of us are A
Spiritual Beings and even if you don't
have dreams even if you don't see things
even if you are this type of person that
you are thinking no but it has to be
statistics there has to be number
there's more than that there has to be
more than that we just haven't been
called to we have been called for more
we have been called to be connected to
God we have been called to to be one
with the Holy Spirit and walk by faith
as the Bible say not by sight not by
numbers but actually by faith so how do
you know that now you're on the right
track meaning back when you were a witch
or certainly when your ancestors were
witches they thought they were doing
good it was white witchcraft right so
they thought that was healing and
helpful and they would feel spirits and
things but they thought it was all nice
and good and comforting and protecting
and all the rest of it so now you're
saying much the same thing you're saying
I have still have a spiritual sense I
feel comforted and protected I think I'm
doing good I so how do you know that
that you're on the right track now when
you were mistaken about being on the
right track before well it's clearly for
me it's clearly obvious when I was
involv in that I was depressed I was
suicid we were involved in drugs we had
addictions we were having nimmers there
was a depression in my family there was
poverty there was destruction Now using
my life you know the Lord has completely
restored me and my family not only me my
mom my brothers my family we don't have
addictions we don't know involv in drugs
I'm not depressed I'm not suicidal I
don't have those type of nightmares I
don't have a sleep paralysis I don't
have that I you had that too sleep
paralysis MH
I it was everything it was that season
that it was so strong that it was just
all was impossible to be in that house
to the point after my dad die after a
few days we we pack a few things and we
left that house because of the
atmosphere that was in that house the
dreams the nightmares that we were
having I will I will see my dad passing
by thinking my Dad's here when he was in
reality a demon passing by my mom tells
me that they I almost tried to come
suicide in the same place where my dad
died I don't remember I have flashes but
I believe I was probably possessed yes
but that point that house was super the
atmosphere there was heavy and after a
few days my mom said like let's run from
here and we just got a few clothes and
and left that house did you sell it I
mean did you you just you literally just
left we still have that house so my mom
um she um the only thing that she knew
by then was um catholism so she just
basically she talked to a priest the
priest went with holy W or something did
some prayers but then it didn't work
when she came back again there was the
atmosphere she she she says that the
house was still really heavy the
atmosphere there and uh after we became
Christians then she just went over with
some pastors they prayed they anointed
the house they break the course we still
have that house and people living there
and they haven't felt anything so you
were able to go back then I haven't I
have only been there once wow my mom has
why do you think the uh the blessing
didn't take because I believe that there
are some some things specifically that
you have to break in a house there are
certain for example this is why
understanding the spiritual realm is so
important right it's not just like going
there and blessing this place I believe
blessing is a powerful things but there
are certain things in the spiritual
realm like the same thing that we did in
the entrance of the house there was a
portal there that have to be closed
there is a portal there that the Cs have
to be broken specific Al in that place
and play the blood of Jesus and close
those things and rebuke the evil forces
that were inside of that house you know
that's that's an important distinction
because for a lot of people who don't
believe in anything spiritual or who
everyone believes in something spiritual
but you know they'll either believe in
crystals and things or they'll believe
in actual like serious meaningful
spiritual things but to to a lot of
people it's all the same just kind of
mumbo jumbo but there's a difference
between just a basic blessing and say
something like the right of exorcism you
know on the traditional baptism there
are three
exorcisms three a poor little baby you
know or an adult who's being baptized
what three exorcisms because they're has
traditionally been an understanding that
there are unclean spirits that prowl
about the world seeking the ruin of
Souls and that the priest has to cast
them out you know specifically act and
that's different than you know a mere
passing blessing or something like that
and what you're describing in your home
is like a witch putting an actual hex on
you or whatever you know I mean that is
some pretty heavy duty stuff you know
maybe the difference between a you know
a 22 rifle and a bazooka or something
like that yeah and it is like that this
is why like as I was saying I believe we
have to understand the spiritual
principles how the spiritual real works
so we can actually help people with the
things that I learned when I was in that
world I have been able to help so many
people now that I am a Christian I have
done multiple Deliverance on people and
that come with generational courses and
they will go to a place and people will
pray for them and nothing happens you
can stop those things when you
understand the spiritual realm you
realize that you now know how to stop
the enemy from advancing so why is the
church not engaging into Warfare because
the church doesn't know how to why is
the church sleeping and allowing the
enemy to advance because the church
doesn't know how the spiritual real
works and how you can actually stop the
enemy from advancing but now it when you
say that is that not similar to to what
you might have said in your witchcraft
days when when you say I can stop this
you don't L do you literally mean you
personally can stop or no you're saying
that God can stop this and you can be an
instrument you know what is the
difference between that occultism and
where we are now the difference is that
when I was in the occultism I had the
power I could do it the way I wanted
when I wanted I didn't have to ask any I
will just do it my spirit guide will
help me to do it now I am a Christian I
don't do anything that's not Guided by
the Holy Spirit yeah yeah if it's not
Guided by the Holy Spirit I'm not doing
it so when I say like we have the power
to do it through Jesus Christ we are the
vessels we are the instrument and this
is the same way that the enemy is
looking for people that live in sin to
advance his kingdom is the same way that
God is looking for holy people to
advance his kingdom so if you see it
follows kind of like the same principle
God is looking for Holy vessels who are
going to S to surrender to him to live
in Holiness so he can use it to advance
his kingdom the same way that's why the
enem is looking to see okay who is
living in sin so I can advance my
kingdom through that through that person
this this is something that is misund
understood there's another another
misunderstood aspect of especially when
when you see an old movie if you're not
a Christian you're not a Catholic you
see an old movie and they go to to
confession people will say well why do I
need to confess my sins to some guy in a
box say well because that some guy is
not acting as himself the traditional
understanding is that he is acting in
the person of Christ you know so you're
confessing your sins to God in in the
Holy Mass the the PR is acting in
Persona Christi and but because we've
lost so much of our understanding of the
spiritual realm and the religious
tradition that was alive and well not
all that long ago people get very
confused and they say well you know the
witches out there doing some kind of
mumbo jumbo and you got the Christian
over there doing some other kind of
mumbo jumbo and know it's all the same
but the the orientation is totally
different as you describing one is
totally self centered and the other is
totally giving away of oneself
selfless exactly that's what St Paul
writes it's no longer I who lives
exactly so that is the difference but
now you know when you understand that
you died with Christ you realize okay it
might be me but it's not me it's Jesus
Through Me So you carry the authority
you enforce Jesus Authority through you
because it's no longer you so wherever
you go there has to be a change in the
at in the atmosphere there has to
Darkness has to start living that place
manifest and living that that place
because you carry light you carry Jesus
so wherever you are walking you are
enforcing that and I believe this is
what a lot of Christians have lost is
that the authority that Jesus Christ
give us the identity that we have in
Jesus Christ to to step into serpents
and to you you you know command the
atmosphere to change on this theme of
acting in public
do you see in the political issues in
the political
fights the clear Christian side because
there are many people who would call
themselves Christians who say look we
don't the church doesn't take doesn't do
partis in politics doesn't it's so much
bigger than that we don't I mean there
there are
people who call themselves Christians
who call themselves priests there was a
a woman I guess a priestess you'd call
her she was in the Church of England and
she said she's a she's pretending to be
a priest and she she said that abortion
can be fine it can be it can be health
care and I think
you as a Christian you are you are in
the name of your faith defending the
human sacrifice of little babies man if
if we can't agree on that political
issue that that is something that a
Christian must oppose well then I guess
we can't be involved in
politics do you see this in in other
political issues yeah
the same with the LGBT is that something
to the
too the same in in that way like there's
so many people that actually they are
Christians but they are accepting what
is happening in the Nations what is
happening in their in their cities and
whether you are a Christian and you're
follower of Christ or you are no you
cannot be lukewarm you cannot be saying
like I am a Christian but you know what
because I don't want drama and I don't
want you know my church or my or my
place to be involved in this are just
going to agree with with what they are
saying you canot be look lukewarm
whether be cold or be H but don't be
lukewarm don't be lukewarm Dante has in
in his conception of Hell the the
lukewarm people are they're sort of on
just on the outside of hell because
they're they can't get into heaven but
even people in Hell find them so
disgusting they just they spit out by
both of them um but then how can a how
can a Christian
be more active in politics what's do we
say just look vote for the conservatives
don't vote for the crazy liberals the
conservatives want good normal policies
and the Liberals want to kill your
babies and chop up your kids and upend
our whole society I mean is it is it
that simple I believe that it's part of
that right I always make sure that you
know just but the most important thing
you know what it is is not about what
are they offering to you I think the
most important thing is like what is the
holy spirit guiding you to to CU the
same way that God can use na kosur or he
can use a wicked person for a nation the
same way the same way that happen in the
Bible God can do it noway so I think the
most important thing for this is to have
the revelation of the Holy Spirit just
come I see a lot of Christians that they
put in a table what are they offering me
oh better jobs better they don't care
that they are you know they are
they are they approve the abortion or
they approve these type of things just
because they see the benefit okay so yes
we need to see what they are offering
but I think everything has to come to
that spiritual perspective okay Holy
Spirit what are you what do you want to
bring what is the changes that you want
to bring because God can use anyone for
a nation God can bring someone that is
like left right but also the most
important thing what is the holy spirit
telling you what is the holy spirit
showing you that's why we have to be a
Spiritual Beings we cannot be normal
people trying to understand spiritual
matters and we don't comprehend this
spiritual realm but now do you do you
mean this when you say listen to what
the holy spirit's telling you do you
mean this is a matter primarily of
private Revelation or public Revelation
in in that when Christ ascends to the
father he says look you're upset that
I'm leaving you but you you should be
happy because I'm going to go up and
then I'm going to to send you a
comforter I'm going to send you the Holy
Spirit and you see this at Pentecost the
Holy Spirit descends tongues of fire and
this is the great expansion of the
church and uh Christ says I'll never
leave you you know the the church will
always have the Holy Spirit um private
I'm a little skeptical of private
Revelation I think there are many
examples of private Revelation that I
find credible that the church has deemed
credible that I think are inspiring I
think it can happen to any of us I think
it does happen to a lot of us May maybe
but demons can appear as angels of light
so that that seems to be a little
worrisome as well and I guess it's why I
I tend to
favor
the hearing the voice of the Holy Spirit
through the church to whom the holy to
to to whom uh our Lord has promised the
holy spirit's Eternal protection does
that make sense I I just I'm I'm a
little worried about someone saying well
I just I just heard the spirit told me
that we've got to elect some crazy baby
killing Democrat because you know I
don't know I just felt it that and this
is why I also believe it's important for
us to be under someone that is you know
seasoned and anointed so whatever you
receive you can go to that person and
wait it there always has to be some sort
of like what you see what the Lord is
showing you that you believe that you
wait that with someone whether is a
prophecy for for a nation whether is a
revelation for the next president that
you actually are under someone because
also the spiritual realm also understand
submission you see like trust me the
demons are
submitted they work in ranks there are
different types of ranks there are
different type of levels this is why
also when I became Christian I saw so
much Division and I'm like how is this
going to even work there they are so
organized understand Rank and then you
we have the church and the in division
like fighting oh you not here I'm from
this like that has to be Unity if we
want to advance the kingdom of God what
about we forget about the denomination
and we actually come together to worship
the one that Jesus Christ in fact that
that's in the Creed one of the four
marks of the church is Unity the church
cannot be divided against herself that
right and yet you see so much div
obviously we see we see a lot of
division among Christians all around us
I love this point on hierarchy and
submission because we live in a modern
age where we're very egal Arian and
nobody's ever supposed to submit to
anybody I I was at a wedding where
people were rewriting the
scripture in order to say that to take
out any word about submission you're not
allowed to have that anymore but of
course there are natural hierarchies and
in fact even in the very controversial
passage which is read at weddings you
know wives submit to your husbands
husbands love your
wives the marriage is supposed to be a
symbol of the relationship between
Christ and his
church and then as you point out
hierarchies within the church and and
and what you're telling me which I
believe is there even hierarchies on the
bad side of things too because it's a
copy the copy huh just a cheap imitation
exactly but you know God is a god of
order and we even see in the Trinity
there is the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit that's the perfect example of how
it should work there should be ranks
there should be submission and um the
coming back to the point that you were
saying about the Revelation right this
is why it's important that if someone is
receiving a revelation you know it's
important to see is that person
submitted to someone is that person
under someone or is that person just
going around releasing everything that
they perceive and not actually having
established spiritual life and that goes
for everyone right like who is who are
you submitted to first of all Jesus
Christ of course but are you submitted
to your husband to your wife are you
who your Authority is there is there a
visible sign of the church and of your
faith I mean even if we're talking about
the the image of the church in your
family is this is there order there
that's that's a a beautiful point on or
we're seeing a lot of social and
political order breaking down all around
us and coincidentally we're seeing that
breaking down as the culture turns away
from God now you turned back to God
are you the anomaly are you cutting
against the current of the whole culture
or is there something in the
air by which people are moving away from
New Age spirituality or call it what it
is witchcraft back to God which way is
which way is the culture going oh that's
a really that's a really good
question um what I have what I'm sensing
around is that the people are hungry R
for Spiritual things yeah even those
that say that you know um we don't
believe in anything I'm just really like
like scienes and statistics and numbers
and things like this but there is a
hunger for a spiritual things and I see
that there is Revival in our s the
people are coming out of of the of the
occultism coming out of the Witchcraft
coming out of saturnism coming out of
all of those things because they have
realized and now their eyes have been
open to this but I also say that I see
those that they don't know where to go
they're gravitating towards that this is
why I believe us as the church we need
to be a strong and talking more about
spiritual things so so they people can
understand that hey you have Jesus in
here you don't need to go to the fake
you don't need to go to the copy cut
there is only one way as I say John 14:6
that way is Jesus Christ that yes you
can access through other ways you are
going to be a thief and a robber this is
the real thing so this is why the church
we have to speak up we have to talk and
be involved and talk more about the
spiritual realm and you know what is
going on in the spiritual realm and you
know with the Holy Spirit and the
Revelation so they don't they don't go
towards what is easy for them and
accessible which is the occultism so I I
see like to answer your question I see
like going both ways I see a lot of
people coming out of that but at the
same time the people are trying to find
an answer so people that know about the
spiritual realm are finding a way in
this site but people that are trying to
find a way what is accessible for them
right now is the occultism maybe it's
because what people are really fleeing
is
atheism you don't hear that much about
atheism anymore I remember 15 years ago
that's all you heard about was Richard
Dawkins and Christopher Hitchens and Sam
Harris and it was probably more a
publishing phenomenon than it was an
actual intellectual movement but it
still dominated the culture for a long
time Bill Mah had his movie making fun
of Christians and you just saw it it was
very popular and it's not as popular
anymore why is that what is popular
right now I think what is popular right
now is the two things you're describing
but I'll be even more specific on
I think New Age woo woo witchcraft is
becoming more explicitly popular the
crystals and the dreamcatchers and all
that and I think that
Orthodoxy traditional religion is
becoming more popular where are you
seeing growth in Christian Life I'll
just use an example of the Catholic
Church you're not seeing growth in
hippie dippy 1970s Boomer practices
you're you seeing growth in not younger
you're actually seeing growth in much
older practices than that the mass of
the ages the Latin mass is exploding and
it's exploding with young people you're
seeing a a big Drive of young people
toward Eastern Orthodoxy you know the
the Eastern take on Christianity even
for my Protestant friends I'm I'm seeing
a collapse in the mainline squishy
lukewarm churches and where there is
growth there would seem to be growth in
more dogmatic more rigorous forms of of
that
so I'm I'm seeing a I guess an emptying
out of the lukewarm squishy middle and a
a clarifying of the battle lines yeah in
the spirit you put it like in the
perfect with the perfect words thank you
the lukew yeah is actually spreading
some people are going to this eye and
some people are going to this eye so
there is there is a Revival there is
something is happening in the spiritual
like people people's eyes are being open
now to the spir to the spiritual realm
now the I feel like the the the danger
is is that that the people are
gravitating towards what is accessible
for them what is easy for them and we
see like everywhere in in the TV like in
the news in the movie but then on the
other side I see also the eyes of people
opening up more to the prophetic the
prophetic is revelation and who is the
one that revealed to us the Holy Spirit
so I see like more people all also like
actually realizing that there is a
spiritual realm that there are demons
that there are things that we can do to
help people to cast out demons in the
name of Jesus and and so I I see Revival
now you you still live in Colombia you
don't live in the United States no so I
grew up in Spain yes then I moved to the
UK when my dad died when I was 18 and I
moved last year to Colombia after 25
years years so do you do you get back to
Spain or to the UK or obviously you're
traveling here but probably just to do
this interview and a few other
professional
things do do you do you ever go back
knowing that there's so much baggage
with your old life there or do you say
no I've got a new life I'm sticking
around Colombia I I went to Colombia
with a mission I went there not because
I wanted to move it was never in my
heart coming back again to my roads
coming back again to my family or to
that place because I always thought if
the Lord took me out of this place is
because he wanted something better but
the Lord I'm sorry you you grew up in
Spain or you grew up in Colombia Spain
you grew up in Spain I was born in
Colombia but you were born in Colombia
okay got I was born there moved to Spain
when I was five yeah and then after my
dad died when I was 18 I moved to the UK
I met my husband there got marryed have
kids and then mov back to Colombia God
sent me back there to to um establish a
new ministry and the word that the lord
gave me was I'm sending you back as I
sent Moses to his people so I believe
that also because of the experience that
I went through the occultist there so
much witchcraft in Latin America is
there is is normal it's the Daily Bread
you're walking on the street and you see
people doing witchcraft in the shops and
I'm like that for me that for me is is
not normal right seeing in the street
and in the shops like the the culture
for me was quite like shocking and uh so
this one year this year that I have been
there I have to you know again connect
to the culture to the people what what
is moving around but I believe the Lord
sent me back is because I had an
understanding of how things work on the
spiritual realm now I have been set free
and now he's taking me back to help my
people too is the Witchcraft in Latin
America is that what santoria is because
I've heard of santoria and I was
interested in it because it's got it
looks kind of Christian specifically
it's got It's got almost the aesthetic
of
Catholicism but it's totally perverted
it's to it's like an in inversion of the
religion where like there's this thing
they worship the uh Saint death
Sant so what is it though it's like a
it's just like a pagan syncretism with
Catholicism so Santa right the s
it has H seven orishas okay Jun Chango
so all of these godess that went the
Afric that they come from Nigeria in
Nigeria you have the seven the same ones
so when the Africans you know they got
slave and they move to Cuba they move to
it this is where is predominant the
Sania Puerto Rico Dominican Republic
these places the culture mix with the
culture of the slaves so and this is why
you know the principality that I was
consecrated to it's called the Indian
waio he's part of the three Venezuelan
Powers so there are different courts you
have the core um what's the name you
have the cor the the Indian core which
is these three Maria Leona negro Felipe
Indian Wai puto that these are the the
three principalities of Venezuela but
then you have the Sania right and this
is where all of these other so all of
these come from the root of Africa these
these goddess these Demons of high rank
and at the time of doing the Sania and
the Witchcraft right what happens is
that now it has mix with catholism even
my great-grandmother for healing she
used to use S Gregorio s Gregory for
healing and uh and and other saints that
she that she used to use mixing them up
with this demon stuff from Africa so
exactly so it's quite common there that
you will see Catholics so involved in
Witchcraft and they say I'm Catholic I'm
going to church I'm practicing and doing
all at the same time they're doing
witchcraft someone asked me about this
this Sant Muerte and I said you know
listen I wasn't totally perfectly
catechized but I never heard of this
Santa Muerte anywhere in my catechism or
any I never read this in the Bible or in
any of my Catholic teaching and I then I
stumbled on this santoria thing that
must that must be very scandalous too
because if these people just in good
faith grow up and they think that
Catholicism is when you invoke like
demons to practice witchcraft
then they they might be doing these bad
things without even really knowing it
yeah and that was like part of my family
too my great grandmother she used to go
to church but then she used to just go
home and be a medion so it's part
especially of the Latin culture is so
strong wow to see Catholics actually
involving Witchcraft and with the Saints
and all and all of that that's why but
are they are they aware of it I just
assumed that they're not aware of it but
are are they aware of the contradiction
there no no no my GRE grand mother s
used to use the Bible too she used to
have the Bible open in Psalms 23 Psalms
91 and even like when my dad died you
know this white witch um she told my mom
do this prayer every night even though
she was a witch she told my mom do this
prayer salm 91 Psalm 23 every night and
we did that for one month every single
night so the they understand that you
know there's something in the Bible I go
to church you know but at the same time
I'm using the Saints and I'm using even
like some rituals that they do they
actually ask God to to bless and to
guide and and the Saints to to to the
intercede and
wow now what about I guess the only
other occult thing I've heard that in
invokes some Catholic practices but
flips them would be outright Satanism
where they do the Black Mass which is a
parody of the of the traditional Holy
Mass but you never got involved in
outright
Satanism thank God I did then but I but
I have an understanding of how things in
Satan isn't work and the same thing they
blow the rituals because we were doing
BL rituals too and animal and things
like that for you were sacrificing
animals for certain rituals you know in
Sania is super common in Sania is super
common to kill maybe a chicken or a um
cows goats sorry C no goats things like
that is is normally is part of the
ritual because you need blood one time I
was walking along Santa Monica Beach in
California and underneath Santa Monica
pure my buddy and I were walking along
we found a beheaded chicken and I had no
idea what this was and I I joked I said
oh I guess he ran out of the restaurant
you know he made it out of the kitchen
before they could cook him but my buddy
said no you know this is probably some
Voodoo thing probably some witchcraft
ritual and I didn't really believe him
when he said it but there's a lot of
occult stuff out in California there is
probably you you see spiritually what it
moves in there and when you see there's
a lot of sexual immorality sexual
immorality comes together with the
occultism sexual immorality moves with
witchcraft he also moves with poverty
and death addictions so when you see in
an area that's moving those type of
things there's some sort of Witchcraft I
I saw a
story just just popped up of a trial in
Glasgow 11 people put on trial for
witchcraft that was the headline really
sensationalist in 2023 people are on TR
for witchcraft but then when they outlin
the actual charges it was Satanic ritual
abuse of children it
was sexual abuse of children and and
forcing children into seances and to use
Ouija boards and it was all it was all
jumbled up together and
uh it did get me wondering
it hate to bring this up you know in
mixed company but is the weird sex stuff
is it's part of it the sex rituals yeah
it is part of it and let's come back
again to the blo thing you you know why
they use virgins in their rituals
because when a virgin woman had sex for
the first time the highman breaks so
there's blood so there is a covenant
there so at the time that's why they use
the virgins for the rituals because
there is a connection there is a
covenant there this pure there's
something there with with that blood
that gets the the the demons and then it
gets more power that's why they also use
children they do in these rituals they
do sorry for being so thinking they they
rape children they they they rape babies
because they believe that there's pure
and there's something there with the
blood that is going to give more power
and more access to the demons for saying
that you will be called conspiracy
theorist qanon that's the new term that
they use whatever it means and they'll
say you you believe that there is this
ritual abuse going on of children and
even babies and I I guess my answer to
that is it's like on the whole
witchcraft
issue for all of human
history people have been explicitly
practicing witchcraft like all tribes
all over the
world there are people today who call
themselves witches there are religious
people who oppose
witchcraft there are in this case people
on trial
for witchcraft related crimes that
include all of those crazy wild
conspiracy theories with the little kids
and the horrible stuff the only people
who don't believe in this are a handful
of I guess secularists or materialist
type people and then I guess there's
another group that denies it which is
the people who are maybe engaging in it
or covering it up and they they're just
lying and so but I just don't see how
looking at the evidence of all of
history and even the headlines and a
trial right now going on in Scotland the
testimony of someone who's been very
involved in witchcraft how how anyone
could deny it all all of the evidence
says this stuff happens and has pretty
much always
happened the enemy wants to make this
look like it doesn't ex six exist so we
don't do anything about it I had
recently recently I was kind of like
mentoring helping someone that she was
involved in Satanic ritual abuse she was
a woman she was a 65 year old woman and
her testimony is crazy and I was trying
to help her to come out of the mentality
helping her with Deliverance with
healing and she told me some crazy stuff
that they used to do to her and people
will hear her testimony and think like
she's crazy she needs to go to a
psychiatric exactly she needs to be L
but she was sharing a specific things
about what she went through and even as
a really young girl how she was raped
how she was involved in this rituals
what they have to make her do when they
Lo her in in in cages with animals to no
that was in the story about what
happened in Glasco they would lock these
kids in cages and cabinets and they and
they locked them there with animals
because their main thing is fear they
want to kind of like control their mind
so then one day they can be part of the
cult and continue in fact fact this
woman she was she became like a high
priest saturnist and um and but she
believed in go and she was young because
she had an encounter with Jesus so she
believes that the whole time the Lord
was protecting her for from those things
but she but she told me some crazy stuff
and I'm like I didn't even know those
things were real like wait hold on she
she believed in God had an encounter
with Jesus and then became a high
ranking they were training her got it to
be a High um satanis and you know she
she had she saw demons she had
encounters she she went through rape M
they even killed one of her babies in in
when she got pregnant as a sacrifice so
the crazy the story is crazy they made
her get an abortion or like after they
took the baby out and they killed in
front of her so there there's these
things are real these things are real
and I'm like but but this is why the
enemy doesn't kind of like want to make
us think that this is not real so we
don't stand and we speak about these
matters we speak about these things and
what are we going to do against that
because if the church doesn't know that
this is real the church is just going to
be sitting my question then I think I
probably know the answer but what kind
of groups are doing this meaning is it
just some weirdo Fringe eccentric people
on the on the edges of Society who are
engaging in this and who get caught up
in it and it's it's horrible and tragic
but it's some pretty weird out there
people or is it mainstream people and
wealthy people and powerful people and I
I you seem to be implying it's the lb so
conspiracy theories again I guess people
are going to think yeah but um I believe
there's so many people in power involved
in Satanism you cannot imagine imine she
even I mean I don't want to know say her
name because she she's quite private but
she told me when she was super involved
in that that there were people of of of
high rank with a lot of money involved
in these rituals yeah involved in these
practices and she didn't give me names
but she said like that she saw a lot of
people with money in power in government
um involved in this type of practices so
I believe that there's a lot of people
there's normal people doing it
and there's also people in power
involved in this I did hear from someone
once this was someone I knew a little
bit in school like freshman year and
then we kind of lost touch one our
separate ways I don't I don't think he
liked me very much you know very
conservative and but he reached out to
me years later after we had graduated
and uh I without going too much into
detail in this because I don't I don't
want to be gossiping or anything it he
got involved he just told me all this
once just right over the phone I haven't
talked to this guy in years he got
involved in all of this kind of
stuff like down to the very worst levels
of it and he said there there were very
very wealthy influential powerful people
invol like not you know not very wealthy
like they have nice houses in the
suburbs like import like private jet
kind of money you know in involved in
this and I I've heard
so that was a I guess a
direct witness or participant I heard
this from and I've heard it from other
people too but it
just on the one hand it seems like
common sense because it's right there in
the
Bible we the principalities and the
powers and the spiritual wickedness of
high places and the notion that the
devil is the prince of this world it's
right there and yet you just even I
still today cannot believe that that is
real because
I just expect things to be kind of more
normal maybe that is normal maybe maybe
the abnormal is normal in this world
exactly there you go so yeah it's
exactly like that we call normal what is
not normal and then the things that are
abnormal those are actually the normal
things so there there's been talk
recently or more attention paid to some
of this ritual abuse and the abuse of
children and trafficking and and all of
that it was the movie sound of freedom
and there's been some attention paid to
this which uh I loved when the sound of
Freedom movie came out the liberal media
said this is a
qanon conspiracy movie or something I
said wait a sec it's based on the true
story of Tim Balor I I interviewed the
guy who these these are real events so
if you're saying that these real events
are conspiracy theories then what are
you saying about the so-called
conspiracy theories
but there's attention paid to that how
does one stop that how do how does one
break up all of these wealthy Elite
cabals of
satanists oh that's good that's
spiritual warfare of high rank not
everyone should be involved in that um I
believe that's why we have to prepare
ourselves I believe there has to be a
spiritual preparation and with that I
mean Holiness making sure that you are
like living the holy life that you fast
that you pray that you intercede you're
connected with the holy spirit that you
closing portals in your life that you if
you have sins in your life you stop them
if you have courses you breaking
generational courses and iniquities as
the Bible says that you have this this
this this training and that you are
trained as a soldier I always see I
always see everything for me everything
that happens in the natural is a
representation of how what is happening
in the spiritual realm right so part of
what I see here with the armies right
how how they get trained how they get
equipped they don't go to attack the
enemy they first investigate who is the
enemy who is the head what is the
weakest Point how we can enter the same
way should be for us we just don't
engage in Warfare for the sake of I cast
out this principle no we actually need
to have understanding who is the person
and the principality that we are facing
who is the spirit of high rank and the
same thing fasting prayer clo close
importance breaking courses and train
also in war waking up early to pray like
this these people train they wake up
early they train they eat healthy same
way for us we don't realize but even
eating yeah certain things affect the
spiritual realm so we are eating all we
eat is Fast Food and Pizza all of that
I'm I'm telling you all of those things
affect the spiritual realm because you
might go to sleep and in the spiritual
realm now you might have nightmares now
you cannot perceive maybe the holy
spirit is trying to give you a dream or
something so all of those things for me
are like important that we actually
understand and we actually trained as
the people in the military here here on
Earth so we can actually be part of
God's Army and part of the occupying
Army so we can understand okay how are
we going to occupy Nations it's not
actually going against the person
because Ephesians 612 says our fight is
not against flesh and blood but against
principalities against the powers so
understanding that we love the person
but we come against the spirit that's
coming behind and this this is what we
have to be prepared for this is what we
have to be ready for if we want to see
actually a change in our nation and
establish the government of Jesus Christ
in that Nation I love the imagery of the
soldier because one of one of my
favorite books on this question is the
spiritual combat by Dom Lorenzo scoy and
he writes about these spiritual
disciplines and and very practical ways
this a 500y old book but very practical
ways to deal with this Vice or that sin
or this temptation When you mention the
food maybe you feel a little sluggish
you have nightmares you don't sleep well
I find the greatest predictor of
of my likelihood my inclination towards
sin and temptation is if I'm tired if
I'm well- rested I'm generally pretty
good if I'm really tired I haven't slept
in a few days I've been overworked I was
out late the night before my temptation
to sin even if it's just a mental sin
even if it's just entertaining wrath or
lust or Pride or anything is is far
basic stuff just get get a good night's
sleep you know like like a soldier a
soldier going out to to a battle if if
he hasn't slept in a few days he's not
going to be as effective as he would
otherwise and I love this idea of being
wise as a serpent innocent as a dove you
know you don't just go out and say here
we go I'm going to I'm just going to
take on all the bad
forces physical and metaphysical today
no you've got to be a little clever and
you've got to have strategy and you've
got toly that's what I tell people that
the same thing that the people of Israel
when they used to go to war they used to
ask the Lord shall we go is this our
time when they didn't ask God if they
should go to war they they used to lose
they used to go into captivity they used
to the same thing happens in the
spiritual realm you're entering into a
fight or a battle that the Lord is not
telling you to enter you're going to
suffer counterattacks because the Lord
hasn't give you the go-ahead to go for
it so for I said I always said this for
every battle that you are facing now on
Earth there is a spiritual strategy that
you should be asking the Lord to give
you to F and and the focus on how how
are we going to stop all this public
evil first step is Holy your personal
Holiness starts in you you know there
are there are people who call themselves
Christians who will say I don't need to
be holy I don't need to work on anything
I don't need to discipline myself I
don't need to fast and pray and do all
the things that Christians have done for
all of human history or for all of the
history of the church and and before
that actually you know in the the people
of Israel you know awaiting the Messiah
I don't need to do any of that I just I
think for many of them they'll say well
I just need to think in my head you know
I I believe in Jesus saying
that's well you know you got a body too
you got we live in time and space too
you know the tree by its fruit too many
people say we'll call me Lord Lord and I
will say I didn't know you and this is
the thing that um that people said like
I just accept Jesus I just go to church
and that's it he done that's the
beginning when you accept Jesus your
spirit gets activated by the Holy Spirit
but we are Tri triin we are spirit so
body what about your soul your soul is
is your mind your emotions what what
about now you working in your soul
because also like if your soul is in
darkness right your mind your emotions
at the time of the Holy Spirit maybe
speaking to you or something is going to
pass to this filter so at the time of
receiving in your natural being is going
to be be Distortion it's going to be
corrupted so this is why for me it's
important when you come to Christ yes
now you have the Holy Spirit now yes but
you have to start working in those areas
that for Generations your ancestors have
been carrying or maybe you have been
involved in in pornography in addictions
in certain things that you have to stop
and you need to have discipline if we
are the you know the army of God we have
to be train as the Army we have to have
discipline we have to be have a
strategies we need to adopt this thing
and this takes me back again to what
what I was telling you that this is why
the church doesn't get involved in
Warfare because they don't know how to
because they don't know that there's a
spiritual principles and things that we
have to put into place we we want to
advance God's kingdom there's a lot of
stuff even for protection right having a
holy life having a consecration having
this communion with the Holy Spirit
brings protection you have closed
portals in your lives and when you are
enter in the enemy's Kingdom he cannot
do anything to you but right but if you
are like casting out demons and you are
doing this and then you are sinning
behind and you know but I can do this
well it's going to happen to you the
same thing that happened to the sons of
Esa right they didn't know Jesus they
knew Paul they didn't know Jesus that's
why knowing Jesus is is is the key
having intimacy is the key to to enter
into Warfare and change change the the
the the trajectory of a Nation you the
the the private sin and I I don't mean
to mock it or I'm not minimizing it in
any way quite the opposite actually but
people write into me about in my mailbag
and people people I talk to priests they
say this is what they hear from 90% of
guys in confession
it's porn which you just mentioned and
so if you saying that sexual immorality
is a big part of Witchcraft and the
Occult and Satanism then what does it
mean that at least since the Advent of
the internet and certainly since the
iPhone porn is everywhere something like
90% plus of men look at it a huge number
of women look at I read somewhere
something like 60% of women look at it
which shocked me the age of of exposure
to it is extremely
young I I don't well I guess I do want
to say that everything has a spiritual
component I because nothing is merely
physical you know it's not we're spirits
too but what is it say that this key
element of Witchcraft is now effectively
ubiquitous that it's everywhere that
that that porn is just everywhere and
that this if sexual immorality is a big
part of Witchcraft in the occult well
what what is the rapid expansion of that
say so if you go if you if we go back to
the Bible and we talk about the Jezebel
spirit The Jezebel spirit she was a
witch right and she had she was in moral
so she was involved in sexual inal
reality so she was released that over a
place I believe that because of
Witchcraft New Age the occultism is
expanding too much that brings the
remember something I want to say
something and is that demons Don't Walk
Alone the principalities they don't walk
by themselves as I said we were talking
about authorities and ranks they move
with with certain powers that come under
them and then they have others that come
under them right witchcraft which is a
new age UL ISM all all of these
practices Satanism all of these things
bring sexual immorality so now because
of the occultism is rapidly spanding in
our Nations we see the sexual immorality
also being released Upon Our Nations so
this is why like when you go to a place
and you see like there's a lot of sexual
immorality and prostitution you know
there's some sort of Witchcraft here
too that's the that's the sign of it or
one of the big signs of it m so then
what does one do do we just ban porn
that's what I would do I but I I don't
know that we can I believe like there's
a strong man for a reason um this is why
coming back again I see the church
fighting in the spiritual realm punching
the air not knowing what they are
punching I see that I see like people
like just but you who are you fighting
against are you who are you coming
against we need to have understanding
that there are strongman and there are
minions if you buy the minions and you
remove the minions the strong strong man
is still there because there is a legal
right so the portal is still open for
this minion to come back again or other
ones to come back again and leave and so
this is why we as the head of Christ we
need to actually see okay what is the
strong man moving in here we just don't
buy porn that's a minion that's just
like the the consequence of something
bigger so we don't buy the porn we don't
buy the addiction what is actually the
big thing that's moving in that in that
in that area okay it could be maybe like
as I said witchcraft it could be like
control and manipulation and that's been
released is not just porn it's actually
understanding what are we binding and
this goes also to a personal level right
let's say that someone is dealing with
addictions the person is dealing with a
lot of addictions poor maybe drug drug
addictions alcoholism the person just
doesn't bind that but actually what if
the strong man in that person's life is
actually rejection it's actually maybe a
traumatic experience that that person
had when they were young that open up
the portal to addiction so when you go
right there to H the person to be set
free from that trauma you are helping
that person to be set free from the
addictions and all all of these things
so it's actually going to the root like
we are like trees and I see a lot of
people cutting the bad fruit of the tree
instead of healing the root root it's
important that we come back what is the
root of the issue what is the root of
the tree so we start to bring healing to
the body of Christ actually to the rope
and not just the lips and cutting and
thinking that I'm just going to cut this
and hope that it's not going to grow up
again it's going to grow up again
because the the the root is ill right so
I believe that that's part of one of the
strategies that the Lord has given me to
help people and to pray for Nations is
actually what is the root what because
sometimes people think they can just go
back into time they say if only we went
back to the 1990s we'd all be happy or
if we went back to the 1950s things
would be better but but I think well
hold on first of all you can't go back
in time but second of all even if you
could go back in time if you just rewind
the the
tape how is it not going to play out
exactly as it already did you know
aren't aren't the seeds of the present
destruction that we're seeing weren't
they swn way back then weren't they swn
even even probably before that so you
mention okay what's what's at the heart
here well at the heart of look if porn
is just one symptom or one expression of
this problem well it's an expression
of the notion that we can do whatever we
want this notion of maximal individual
autonomy self- sovereignty that's a much
deeper bigger stronger mankind of a
problem than just uh looking you know
getting your jollies off on some
internet video uh the the problem of
people who are in the porn industry
every single every single woman who's
ever been involved in porn has an issue
with her father right you I mean you
just interview after interview testimony
after testimony I mean there's no it's
100% of the time well that would be a
Rude problem and
so if you only prune away at the leaves
well and the root is still there it's
just going to continue to grow so then
there are these deeper problems and
obviously ultimately we can trace this
all the way back to the Garden of Eden
but it does seem that politically there
are some some things that that we could
do that are practical and and that we
could take immediately you mention
strong man and now today if you ever
oppose this liberalism this decadence
this uh sin and debauchery you're called
an authoritarian it's very you want to
get rid of porn you're an authoritarian
you want to you want to suggest that
Christianity is a better basis for
culture
than I don't know Pride parades you're
an authoritarian they've said this about
uh Victor Orban in Hungary they've said
he's an author this guy's been popularly
elected many times and but he said no
our our country is going to be a
Christian country we're not going to
force you to go to church we're not
going to force you to worship anyway but
the C the the country is going to be
oriented toward God and for this every
country around the West is at this guy's
throat they want to attack him but that
seems like a a practical thing that one
could do in politics
100% 100% And this is coming back again
it is about the Authority the person
that is there is like in the spiritual
has kind of like given the keys of that
Nation so whatever you speak over that
nation is going to be released because
you have authority the same thing that
the parents have authority over the
children right we are the head of our
children so when we speak those things
over their life is released in the
spiritual atmosphere and it manifest the
same thing happened to the Nations so
what it would be a good way of actually
changing a nation apart from the
spiritual M matters is actually
establish establishing someone in power
that has the heart of God that are going
to actually release those things over
the nation and say like a strongman you
are not going to rule in this nation
this is who is going to rule this nation
and and is Jesus but this is why the
enemy is taking over the nation because
he knows that if you take the Nations
you change society yeah and the family
is the nucleus of society so how do you
actually stop the enemy from doing that
from here from the government from
standing in this place of authority
changing the government changing the
society and changing the families
because on the political left you'll
you'll see this attack on order and
hierarchy and
law you come to expect that this
divisive atomizing uh political program
but you hear it sometimes even on the
right the right is is alert I to the
notion of Authority or submission to
just Authority but you know it's right
there in the Bible I mean St Paul tells
first of all it's throughout the Old
Testament but then St Paul tells us the
Civil Authority is put there by God for
your good the law is good order is good
and uh
so there's nothing
unchristian about wielding political
power in a just way and yet many in the
church seem to think that there is I
know there's a a lot of people that
actually say we shouldn't be involved in
politics we shouldn't be involved in
anything we're just going to be sitting
in church clapping hands every Sunday
praising and that's it while the enemy
right there no we should be I believe we
should we shouldn't just be even taking
the government we should be taking the
media we should be taking we should be
taking everything yeah for Jesus right
why wouldn't why wouldn't we I mean this
is because what the the Liberals would
would say is well you know you you sound
power mad or you sound R I think well
someone's going to run the media do I
want do I want it to be the people who
are right and inclin to do good things
or the people who presently run the
media who are these crazy Libs who want
to destroy our
civilization somebody is going to wield
the power exactly some there's going to
be some kind of order you're not going
to just live in chaos forever so there's
some kind of order will be imposed you
want it to be an order that is conducive
to flourishing or one that is degrading
and commiserating and that leads to
decline plummeting rates of marriage
plummeting birth rates skyrocketing
rates of suicide so much so that you've
got it now a decreasing life expectancy
in the United States for goodness sakes
uh you political chaos open borders you
go down the Litany of symptoms you're
going to have some kind of
order why isn't it the good one exactly
and this is why also the same way the
Christians say the money having too much
money money is actually bad it is bad
what is the motive of your heart it can
we actually need money to God's kingdom
Yeah we actually need money you want to
in government you need money you want to
in media you need money you want to in
politics and all of these things you
need money so we actually need money we
need the Holy Spirit mainly to make to
make that clear but we also need some
sort of like power to establish that
Aristotle points this out too he says to
be happy money is not going money is not
virtuous you know it's a wealth is not a
like a a virtue and it's just an
instrument for other things instrument
exactly but in order to be happy you do
need to satisfy certain basic material
physical needs so you can you know
people often say money is the root of
all evil but that's not the verse the
love of money is the root of all evil to
make an idol out of money to worship
Mammon that that would be quite evil but
but to do things in the physical world
and and the example I mean going full
circle the example of Witchcraft is
instructive here a kind of parody Or
inversion of true Spiritual Authority
which is the thing that's confounding
for us I think is that it's not that
people have spiritual inclinations one
way or the other but that people would
actually go out into the woods and look
up at a moon and engage in some weird
ritual and cast a magic spell and that
that's the part I think it's the the
fleshy part of it that is so confounding
to Modern liberal people but
historically speaking those of us who
doubt the importance of the physical and
we're the
exception there this has been going on
for a very long time
and there are rituals and sacraments we
might call them uh on the good side too
that's maybe we maybe we ought to be a
little active in those too yeah it's
suly and you know something that I also
realize is that we are some people might
be thinking about those rituals in the
morning oh yeah that's so like that's
coming that's coming out of a book
that's too crazy but you know that some
people actually in those meetings they
are doing the curses for the Nations
they are like releasing on CS in the
nation because they want maybe the LGBT
agenda to go forward maybe they want the
abortions to go forward maybe they want
all the the marriage same sex to go
certain things those things are also
done in those places and that's why for
me like when people laugh at that I'm
like you're laughing at that but the
enem is advancing the enemy is is
releasing those things over our families
and over our nation so right yeah you
you modern glib liberal you're laughing
at it but the people who are regularly
doing these rituals who now we're even
seeing this in courts they're doing
these things they're not laughing the
people in high positions of political
Authority John pedesta who's going to
these dinners running Hillary Clinton's
campaign he's not laughing to doing it
the the vast majority of people from
very poor uninfluential people all the
way up to some of the most influential
people in the history of the world
they're not laughing at it exactly and
you know something curious that I
realize those that don't believe in the
spiritual realm or they're laughing
about what is going on when you look at
their family those are the one that are
more bind in their family those are the
one that have maybe the depression maybe
they have the anxiety the suicide the
thoughts the drug addiction the immoral
part those are the ones that are
actually struggling in those in those
areas and you realize people are so
blind the bible say that the scales of
the eyes fail right there's people that
have a scales in their eyes and stop
them from actually see when their scales
are removed they actually realize this
was in front of me the whole time this
is real okay how can I restore my family
how can I bring this to my family how
can I bring Jesus to my family to
receive
salvation here's to hoping many more
scales fall Amen in their due time Julie
where can people find you well I'm on
social media I'm I'm everywhere you're
everywhere you're in Colombia Spain UK
America in the USA I'm I'm I'm actually
on on on Instagram and on I I have my
YouTube channel where I put um teachings
there Julie Lopez I also run a Ministry
called Rick latam
rig it means restoring the isachar
generation that's the prophetic tribe
that understood times some season so I'm
part of the ministry called Rick Nation
Under Tommy arayomi and our mission is
to basically train people to hear the
voice of God restoring that tribe that
tribe that understand times and season
and what the Nations should do and um so
that's called Rick latam so we are we
are in on Instagram YouTube we have our
website Rick Rick latam and my website
Julie Lopez too you can find you in all
those places and not and not on a
broomstick trulie thank you for coming
on thank you so
much